COMMITTEE MEETING THE CHAIR
SORRY FOR BEING A HALF HOUR
LATE LET'S BEGIN TO ROLL CALL.
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY YES MA'AM
POWER CAN. DEEP. KAMLAGER-DOVE
QUIRK HERE WICKS. OF. ALBANY.
MISTER CHAIR. MARYLAND WAITING
FOR THIS. MAY I START WITH AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR YES YOU MAY
AB FORTY FIFTY FOUR MAKES
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE YOUTH
REINVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WE AS A LEGISLATURE FUNDED IN
THE BUDGET LAST FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS THIS BILL INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF TECHNICAL FIXES THAT
MAKE IT EASIER FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO APPLY FOR
GRANTS AND ENSURES THAT THESE
FUNDS ARE USED FOR YOU
SUCCESSFUL USED DIVERSION
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE THIS BILL
ALLOWS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
TO APPLY FOR GRANTS. AND
INCREASES THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT TO
TWO MILLION DIGITS SHE IS A
REPORT TO INSURE THAT THESE
COUNTRIES ALL PARTS OF THE
STATE GIVING YOU THE OUT OF THE
PRISON SYSTEM CONNECTING THEM
TO SUPPORT A SERVICE NOT ONLY
THE RIGHT THING TO DO BUT ALSO
REPRESENTS HUGE COST SAVINGS TO
THE SAY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. ABOUT OPPOSITION.
THE DíAS. COMMENTS. THAT WAS A
GOOD SINGER AND SING THE
JEOPARDY. THIS IS ACTUALLY
QUITE ENJOYABLE. MAKING
EVERYBODY FEEL A LITTLE BIT OUT
OF THEIR COMFORT ZONE WHICH IS
GOOD. AND THERE'S A REASON. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION YEAH WE DO WE
DO. WE DO. OKAY WHEN I CALL FOR
THE QUESTION. I AB FOURTEEN FOR
THE MOTION IS TO BE CONCURRED
AND JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY
AYE BARRICADE HAN. BARRICADE
HAND I DEEP DEEP I
KAMLAGER-DOVE KAMLAGER-DOVE I
QUIRK QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO WICKS
WICKS I. ROGER PASSES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN READY
FOR YOUR NEXT YES VOTE. A TWO
DAY OR LIKE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN WHICH WAS
AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO SIMPLY
CLARIFY EXISTING LAW AND CODIFY
APPELLATE COURT CASES REGARDING
PLEA BARGAINS UNFORTUNATELY A
LOWER COURT DECISION CREATED
SOME CONFUSION ABOUT HOW STATE
LAW APPLIES TO PLEA BARGAIN.
THE CLEAR UP THIS CONFUSION AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN WHICH STATE
THAT THE DEFENDANT IS NOT ABLE
TO SIGN AWAY THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
FUTURE LEGISLATION IS A
REASONABLE CHANGE THAT PRESERVE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS ENSURES THAT CHANGES
MADE THE STATE LAW BY THIS BODY
OR THE VOTERS ARE NOT
CIRCUMVENTED ARE YOU SURPRISED
LOCAL PROSECUTORS. NO ONE
SHOULD BE ASKED TO SIGN AWAY
RIGHTS WHEN THEY DO NOT KNOW
WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE. THANK
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. K. ANY OTHER OF WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. CAN WE ARE FIRST AND
SECOND CALL FOR QUESTIONS. I
MAY BE SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO BE HEARD IN JONES
SAWYER DANCER IRAQI HI LACKEY
AYE OUR CAN. I CAN I A DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE OF.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK. QUIRK
AYE SANTIAGO WICKS WICKS I.
MEASURE PASSES. READING YOUR. I
DON'T KNOW THAT YOU WANT TO.
YEAH AND WE. I APOLOGIZE AGAIN
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
BEING LATE. AND IT CLOSE TO
COMMIT. BUT WHAT I WAS GOOD. WE
STAND ADJOURNED. THE